so what is this thing called nac n acetyl
l cysteine what is that that doesn't
explain anything well that's a stable form of
cysteine which still doesn't explain anything
cystine is a non-essential amino acid basically
it's a stabilizer for the formation of protein
structures in your body which still doesn't give
you a lot of information so i'm just going to go
into the benefits of what this is and how it can
help you first of all it's something that can
increase one of the most powerful antioxidants
in your body called glutathione which means it
can help counter things like alcohol toxicity the
toxic effects from certain medications that treat
adhd it can help reduce acne especially the scars
from acne it can definitely help reduce addictions
like all addictions cocaine alcohol nicotine
food addictions because nac helps normalize
neurotransmitters like glutamine and
dopamine which are both involved in
addictions it can help copd which is chronic
obstructive pulmonary disease because with
this condition there's a lot of oxidation
going on and inflammation nac helps reduce
mucus so it's good in pneumonia lung issues asthma
bronchitis number seven it can help reduce ocd
symptoms obsessive compulsive disorder symptoms
number eight it can help reduce depression
because it affects the neurotransmitters as
well as anxiety number nine relieves autism why
because it affects the neurotransmitters
of the brain number ten it can help certain
disorders like bipolar and even schizophrenia
why because it affects the neurotransmitters
and number 11 i did an entire video on this
it can help limit tylenol induced liver damage
why because it's a very powerful antioxidant
all right there you go i hope that helped you
in understanding what nac really is hey before
you go real quick i have a course entitled
how to bulletproof your immune system it's a
free course i want you to take it and here's why
here's you here is your environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here what about
strengthening your immune system that's what's
missing this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can tolerate
and resist your environment much better by
strengthening your own immune system i put
a link down in the description right down
below check it out and get signed up today